the question then for you becomes
uh this is a question i've i've been you
know been trying to get an answer from
somebody we had the press secretary of
uh desantis here christine
right
and she was a great uh she was great at
playing dodgeball i mean like she was
she wasn't a great dodgeball player
she was dodging everything every time i
was asking like this it was very
impressive but uh this is this is a
state where they love their governor
and in some communities they love their
former president in this state right so
they're conflicted in the state of
florida
a lot of people on the center and on the
right would like to see desantis get in
the ring and compete for the number one
spot which is to be the president
there's even some people on the left
that would be more happier with a
desantis than they would be with a
trump as a president right
but right now if you go out there and
you look at who's going to be the you
know candidate for the right no one the
percentage-wise trump's at the top he's
got a good lead on desantis right
and if this in the then the question
becomes well if desantis doesn't run
right now
you know politics people got a short
memory you know because newsome maybe
they're canada in 2023 2024 and people
forget about what happened in california
so that's my i think it's trump versus
newsham in 2024 by the way okay got it
so so so so you don't think the santa's
going to run this year in 2023 2024.
i think that i think governor desantis
wants to run
i think that desantis is a powerhouse
and i think that he would uh if the
election were tomorrow and trump was not
in the race desantis would he'd be the
next president of course if he's not
right the one thing that i would say i
don't i i don't know about president i
think he would have a very high chance
of being a president but i think he
would take the republican side the
nominee
i've seen i've seen polling that says
that again if president trump did not
run and the election were tomorrow so
it's not based on going through the
campaign trail the gauntlet and and by
the way it's a long road to the
coordination so a lot of you know a lot
of the roadside's littered with
candidates who are the front runner and
then they get that wrong or that one
weird question or they get tripped up or
people see some weird awkwardness about
them or something like that and they
they stumble uh ron would win the gop
primary and then he would beat whoever
the democrat nominee is it's just that
biden's really screwed things up for the
political left right now
i do think that president trump runs i
think maybe to your point again this is
not something i'm not saying this from
anything he told me yesterday because we
didn't go into anything specific but
look you take a trump desantis ticket
something like that would be pretty damn
powerful in my opinion um and maybe a
team up there might be a smart thing
that uh that helps the gop take it
overall i don't i don't know if that
happens
i don't know if that happens these are
two alphas i just i have a hard time
seeing desantis doing that uh but but at
the same time if they go at each other
what does it look like if they both run
i've seen all the quotes all the things
trump has said i would beat him too you
know
you know the booster shot hey i have
people ask me if i took the bootstrap i
did some people are afraid to see i've
followed all the stories everything
that's been happening but uh what
happens if both of them run
is that a good thing or
it's i'd prefer to avoid it i still
think trump wins uh i don't even think
that it's it's ultimately close uh but
it would uh i think that again ron's a
powerhouse trump's a bigger powerhouse
what about his relationship with pence
these days pence may be considering
running as well they haven't exactly uh
mince words as a plate
where's things stand with pence yeah i
don't think they're hanging out on the
weekends anymore so i think that that
ship has probably sailed so uh any
chance that if trump uh runs again that
the uh pence would be his vp nomination
at all
i can't see it
zero i think it's zero i don't think
it's possible
i don't think it's possible for that to
happen but indeed would run though no
don't you think
like looking on stage you see a trump
you see a pence you see a nikki haley
you see a desantis
what does that look like there and
there's here's the reality if you look
at the polling
um
desantis has already clearly passed
pence i mean even if even if president
trump did not run for some reason uh if
president trump did not run i do think
pence definitely then runs uh and uh if
i were advising him i'd say not to
because i think desantis would uh would
clean his clock
the santas would clean this clock
pence's yes yeah i don't disagree you
see trump and pence
debating on stage
i mean certainly if uh
i mean if there was a primary field and
they had primary debates i think
actually i think trump would probably
love that uh it would be it'd be you
know it'd be
made for uh tv excitement i don't think
pence would do it i don't think pence is
gonna run
because the this okay so what's pence's
uh message gonna be let's actually go
there first debate there on stage i was
with trump 99.9 of the time until
january 6 insurrection so okay so who
does he get he gets the lincoln project
folks yep he gets the bush camp he gets
mcconnell who does he get karl rove he
gets karl rove he gets those guys that's
who he's gonna get okay what happened
the moment biden one what did they do to
lincoln project nothing they realized
you're left out there too so lincoln
project is also sitting there
they're probably behind closed doors
hoping for a desantis hoping for
somebody else because those guys are not
going to support trump but pence's
argument is going to be it's only so
it's only going to last for a week or
two before he's done i don't think
that's going to last um but don't forget
that pence was a nobody before trump
made him well i will tell you this
i get what you're saying i get what no
he has a point to say when to me how i
interpret that is he wasn't mainstream
that's a better way of saying it not
that he was a nobody i will tell you a
lot of people voted for trump because
they were glad pence was the vp so you
can't say he was a nobody especially
so if you think about if you think about
percentage-wise out of all the votes he
got when he beat hillary okay what
percentage you think was uh was pence so
i can tell you just put a little numbers
to that
in the final debate that president trump
had in toward the end of it when he
answered the question about supreme
court picks is it in 16 uh yes in 16
sorry
in 2016.
we our numbers went from mid high 80s
with republicans to
low mid 90s with republicans after that
answer because people uh heard the okay
uh these pro-life they once conservative
supreme court judges support the second
amendment uh but it's it's that was much
more of the pence voter they kind of
took it from the
mid high 80s to the low mid 90s so
you're exactly right there there was a
definitely community of folks that
pushed him over and was 77 000 votes
over six states yeah you could say pence
was a huge part of it so if you enjoyed
this little short segment from the
podcast that we did here's another short
segment to watch or if you want to see
the entire podcast click over here take
care everybody bye-bye
[Music]